i have a question as well uh you talked
about as being a
secular jew in terms of that over time
kind of the the religion erodes and it
kind of goes downwards uh do you think
that the role of
uh religion has what that has played in
history has been a overall good thing or
a bad thing
god you guys are unbelievable these are
incredibly difficult questions i just
had occasion to write a long essay about
the british empire
was the british empire from 1600 to
1949 when it finally ended or 1960 when
all the the various colonies gained
independence was it a force for good or
a force for bad
and you look at it you study it
seriously you studied it historically
you come to the conclusion it's too soon
to tell
well you think it's any easier
to make the claim with respect to the
roman empire say from the age of
augustus to the fifth century when the
roman empire in the west collapsed
historians are still enraged with one
another because one half of the
historical community said we'll say ah
the roman empire was rapacious it was
cruel it was monstrous overbearing dr
johnson has a as a famous remark about
the roman empire these people
lived by stealing from
from strangers and when they ran out of
strangers from which to steal they stole
from one another
that was his view of the romans
on the other hand we have to say without
the roman empire
the entire glorious tradition of western
history would have been aborted
2 000 years ago
so it's a very difficult question to
answer
has the role of religion has religion
been a good thing overall has it been a
bad thing it's been an inescapable thing
it's been a necessary feature of our
existence and we can certainly point to
good things and bad things obviously so
the good things
and the bad things
don't quite get to the essence
of the moral question we were talking
about an hour an hour and a half ago
whether without the structure
of divine authority
a completely moral
or acceptable social life is possible
that's a question that we have yet to
answer so i got so since
maybe our booker didn't manage
expectation he should have said we only
ask tough questions but i got a question
for you i think you may like and it's
not going to be complicated go ahead do
you like ice cream
yeah okay then so you can't tell us all
we do is ask you tough questions that's
a very spiritual experience for some
people when they have the right kind of
ice cream if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you